hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo lo
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
ya son más de 3 millones los refugiados
que salieron por la guerra en ucrania y
entre ellos al menos 75.000 niños huyen
cada día según unicef
ante tal éxodo es vital la ayuda que
proporcionan los países de acogida un
apoyo que se da gracias a medidas
nacionales y decisiones particulares
para aliviar la situación de los recién
llegados polonia continúa como el mayor
receptor del éxodo ucraniano y hasta esa
frontera llegaron bomberos franceses
para ayudar a los refugiados el informes
de nuestros periodistas en terreno
son varios los que se encuentran en la
frontera polaca con ucrania bomberos
franceses voluntarios y distintos
profesionales para ayudar en la llegada
de miles de refugiados como aquí en
media acá
nos gustamos dando el máximo hacemos
turnos día y noche como los demás no
tenemos más mérito que nadie estamos
aquí para ayudar para dar apoyo el flujo
de migrantes es muy regular nosotros nos
adaptamos a los cuidados que necesitan
salud ayuda psicológica atendemos a los
bebés hidratando los hubo varios casos
de hipotermia y estamos tratando de
auxiliar a todos ellos para su bienestar
una palabra amable
a 50 kilómetros de médica de meier otro
punto de control fronterizo
aquí los bomberos de la región francesa
de oshawa hacen la cobertura a sus
compañeros polacos acogen a cada uno de
los refugiados en su gran mayoría
mujeres niños y ancianos
los bomberos trasladan sus equipajes los
atienden y los llevan hasta sus refugios
de emergencia o hasta la estación más
cercana para que aquellos que desean
continuar su viaje como esta familia que
recién llegó
llegamos de ucrania en nuestra ciudad
natal nuestra gente está sufriendo mucho
hay mucha destrucción mucho miedo no hay
paz y nosotros tenemos niños amamos
nuestro país y no queríamos marcharnos
estamos verdaderamente preocupados por
los hombres que se quedaron allá
combatiendo en maranello temer nanas
araña sin ellos con la pala metió fea
como bomberos no estamos acostumbrados a
realizar este tipo de tareas por
supuesto ayudamos a gente a diario pero
normalmente no viajamos hasta la
frontera de un país en guerra es lo que
está pasando a 20 kilómetros de nuestra
posición actual
posición
en la frontera entre ucrania y polonia
como tantos otros trabajadores
humanitarios los bomberos franceses
intentan ayudar en la crisis humanitaria
que muchos temen podría estar solo
comenzando
gracias a un proceso simple y rápido la
unión europea activó un esquema de
protección temporal para los refugiados
ucranianos que les permite obtener una
residencia educación e incluso un
trabajo países como polonia moldavia
italia y francia- ya le han dado la
bienvenida a los menores refugiados en
las escuelas veamos como son recibidos
en el informe de ariana villacorta
este es el instituto lima nose que
ubicado en polonia tras la invasión rusa
ucrania abrió sus puertas a estudiantes
refugiados como svitlana y alexander
aquí nos recibieron muy bien desde el
primer minuto estamos muy agradecidos
con el director nos habló en ucraniano
llevaba una insignia con una bandera
ucraniana nos llamaron la atención todos
los carteles en ucraniano y el apoyo
estamos felices de estar en esta escuela
no vamos a buscar otra y nos gustaría
quedarnos
en las clases serán impartidas por
profesores ucranianos que huyeron de la
guerra y contarán con un educador
bilingüe al frente de cada grupo km de
ahí en esta escuela en italia también
recibieron a varios niños ucranianos con
un ambiente festivo y contarán con el
apoyo de un mediador cultural y un
psicólogo para apoyarlos ante posibles
secuelas tras los bombardeos secuelas de
las que habla a lilia que ahora reside
en moldavia
y en casa sentía miedo y temor porque
estábamos constantemente en los pasillos
y en el sótano de un árbol en el que el
dolor aquí está mejor al menos puedes
dormir tranquilo unas palabras que
coinciden con las de este niño de 10
años que llegó a francia para
incorporarse a esta escuela
[Música]
durante los recreos en nuestras escuelas
no salíamos a jugar a la calle
la primera dama a brigitte mccone le dio
la bienvenida a estos menores que
salieron de ucrania el 24 de febrero
cuando empezó la invasión pero a pesar
de la cálida bienvenida muchos
refugiados esperan que el conflicto
acabe para volver a sus hogares
muchos
sólo esperamos que esta guerra termine
lo antes posible y que podamos volver a
kiev y ayudar a reconstruirlas
en medio de la crisis y el dolor los
ucranianos que han huido de su país
rescatan la solidaridad y la acogida que
se les brinda alrededor del mundo
de los desafíos más difíciles dentro del
proceso de refugio es la integración las
medidas urgentes para responder al éxodo
no deben ser transitorias sino estables
y duraderas para garantizar la
protección de quienes huyeron de sus
países hasta que inmigrantes de france24
los invitamos a comentar en nuestras
redes sociales con el hashtag migrantes
efe 24 sigan con más información en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]